in a detention camp in Syria since 2019
shamima begum is stuck in this strange
indefinite Purgatory based on a decision
she made at the age of 15.
and a set of rulings in London the most
recent by the immigrations appeals
commission saying the Home Secretary had
every right to withdraw her citizenship
they implication the outcome that we
face is that no British child who has
been trafficked outside the UK
will be protected
by the British state if the Home
Secretary invokes National Security
her lawyers had argued that when begum
set out from bethnal green with two
friends to join Isis in Syria she was
effectively being groomed and trafficked
and that the government's own
counter-terrorism strategy identified
this problem
but the state says she went with her
eyes wide open to the horrors of this
group and remains a threat to National
Security
well look I welcome the Court's decision
uh but you'll understand I can't uh
comment more because there are legal
considerations ongoing I just welcome
the fact that the government has and
always will take all actions necessary
to defend the British people judge
Robert J said reasonable people will
differ as to the threat she posed in
February 2019 to the National Security
of the United Kingdom and as to how that
threat should be balanced against all
countervailing considerations however
under our constitutional settlement
these sensitive issues are for the
Secretary of State to evaluate and not
for the commission
so essentially it's a political decision
but the UK is an outlier on this
most countries are now slowly bringing
back their women and their children and
France over 100 Germany over a hundred
so the UK is beginning to look a little
bit in an isolated position here
shamima begum hasn't responded to the
ruling when she first emerged From the
Ashes of the so-called Isis caliphate
she showed little remorse
I don't regret because I it's changed me
as a person It's Made Me Stronger
tougher you know I married my husband I
wouldn't have found someone like him
back in the UK
but more recently she insists she should
be allowed to face Justice in the UK
I feel like the only crime I committed
was coming here so I would be willing to
go to prison for that but like for the
accusations made against me I'm just
gonna have to fight against them
shamima begum's lawyers say the fight
goes on though but perhaps her best hope
is for a more sympathetic Home Secretary
Jason Farrell Sky News